what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so after much anticipation we are
finally covering Deathstroke versus
Batman in DC rebirth Deathstroke versus
Batman is one of these things like
Batman vs Superman it's one of these
things that a lot of people really like
to debate and this has been done before
but the cool thing is that the way
Christopher priest does this is actually
different from what we've seen before it
invokes a lot of really great themes and
really one of the biggest questions to
come out of come out of DC rebirth
regarding the character of Damian Wayne
now one of the things to also bear in
mind here when it comes to Christopher
priest and this is something to be aware
of going into his Deathstroke story if
you guys you know go out and buy the
comics it's he doesn't tell them in a
linear fashion which is to say ABCD he
tells them very much in like a kind of
chaotic fashion to a degree in the sense
that he'll he'll tell he'll tell a part
of the story then you'll get a flashback
and then yo tell more the story they
don't do a flashback for the first
flashback and then a flash-forward and
it'll just kind of bounce around all
over the place now fortunately for us
and this story it's not nearly as
complicated as the first arc from from
Deathstroke but there are some things we
can kind of bounce up we can kind of
skip over and then some things we do
need to include but of course this
initially picks up with basically like a
bank robbery but there's an envelope
that's been left here that was
discovered by James Gordon
that's for Bruce Wayne himself and Bruce
Wayne is just kind of like okay and so
from there he ends up tracking the guys
down and basically says look like it has
to be one of these perpetrators who left
the envelope behind now this is a very
very important thing it seems small but
it's very very important and the reason
why is because for a lot of people who
sit down in and read Batman stories one
of the things that people have a
tendency to do is to look at the
character of Batman and see em as this
kind of know-it-all but the cool thing
about this is that it goes into this
idea that Batman doesn't doesn't have
all the pieces he's figuring out just
like everybody else and so where he
takes these guys out he really brings
out the envelope and says you know tell
me what's going on with this give me all
the information you have on this thing
but what we end up doing is having him
go through look at the contents of this
of this envelope only for us to find out
it comes from Biogen labs and it's a DNA
test it's a DNA and paternity test
and what does DNA and paternity test
basically seems to indicate is that
Batman is not thus not the father of
Damian Wayne and this is kind of a big
thing because that's the whole basis
behind Damian Wayne Damian is the son of
Bruce that he was conceived you know
well basically Batman was you know
violated more or less I mean you know
enter nan you know whatever whatever
phrase YouTube needs in order to keep
from D monetized in the video because at
this point everybody's walking on
Shell's YouTube but um you know
basically Batman was violated by Talia
al Ghul he was forced into intercourse
or really kind of knocked out and then
used and then of course Damian Wayne was
born some time later but the idea behind
Amy has always been that he was the son
that he is the son of Bruce and to have
it thrown in there that this is not the
case is actually a pretty big deal
because what he ends up doing is saying
okay somebody has to know what's going
on here which leads him to tracking down
Slade Wilson now initially when he goes
after him it turns out it's a decoy and
then the real Slade Wilson is is really
just kind of around there and that's why
he basically jumps in and immediately
goes to attacks latest says you have to
be the one who knows what's going on
somebody here has to have information
and I'm starting with you and it's kind
of cool because were the two of them
were sort of going at it Slade Wilson
has this this AI called Billy which
really kind of powers a suit to a degree
and then of course while that's going on
his suits basically timing out and
shutting down which Batman uses the
advantage of and when the batwing comes
in Slade Wilson in turn activates his
own device that basically takes out the
auto autopilot aspect of the of the
batwing so is it's really really cool
because you're talking about guys that
have like all these different variations
all these different abilities and these
tricks of the trade and things they can
use to their own advantage and so once
it's all said and done
Slade Wilson kind of kind of says okay
look we need to stop and we need to
figure out what the heck is going on
like like what is up with all this and
this is when Batman reveals to Slade
Wilson this DNA test not only says that
I'm that I'm not the father of Damian
Wayne it says that you are and this is
the meat and potatoes of why he went
after him because what this test
indicates is that Deathstroke is the
father of Damian and this is kind of a
big deal this is a pretty significant
thing now a Slade really kind of chimes
in and says there's no way this is
possible and that man's like yeah I know
it's not but we have to find out what's
going on but notices that man wouldn't
be chasing after Slade so hard if he
didn't believe there was some
possibility that it was true that it
could very well be true and so in this
moment Batman kind of has this small
reserve that Damian is the son of Slade
but Slade just kind of like knocks the
software off the bat he's like don't
want to have anything to do with it
that's kind of an important thing
because Batman picks up on that
immediately you know and so bad I had
response to this is fun they're like
then we're shutting down Deathstroke
basically like every single every single
contract you have I will get in the way
I will slow it down I will do everything
I can every single person that you have
to do that you're gonna go after like I
will move them out of your way and I'll
make it impossible for you to make any
money and so it's kind of interesting
thing we're not really told explicitly
why Batman does this and this is one of
the things you're gonna notice in this
story Christopher
just sort of takes liberties and Batman
just does things because and one one of
the more notable instances what you end
up having is once late in this guy are
heading back to whoever it is they're
supposed to be going their plane is
basically shot down by a by just
somebody in the desert with a rocket
launcher and when Slade goes to attack
this guy when he goes to basically take
him out we end up finding out this
person is Batman the Batman shot down
the the jet of Slade Wilson now at the
outset and this is one of the the
interesting things about this at the
outset going and looking at like like
Twitter posts and looking at like you
know like how about a combined pose and
reviews and things like that one of the
big things people picked up on right off
the bat is something like this it's very
much outside the wheelhouse of Batman
Batman doesn't shoot things down with a
rocket launcher it's just not what he
does it's not his normal thing and
Christopher priest plays on this
perfectly because where we would look at
that and we would say well that's
ridiculous Batman wouldn't do that
what is up happening is when when
Deathstroke yo basically goes to attack
what we think is Bruce heat starts to
beg for his life that's something that
man never does and then when Deathstroke
unmasked him it's just a normal guy now
at this point we transition over to to
takane Adaline or i guess - adaleen cain
this is the ex-wife of Slade now for
those guys who were curious about this
there were a lot of things that drove a
wedge between the two there were two
people who never had any business
getting together in the first place and
of course the first story arc really
explores a lot of that stuff but she
essentially works for defiance kind of
like defines Incorporated or like
defiance as a name it's basically an
intelligence operative that kind of
operates outside the federal government
which is a contractor for the government
and so they have access to all kinds of
information different things like that
Bruce showing up here and asking
questions to her is what is going on
here you have to have like somebody has
to have answers about this what do you
know about the whole idea of like Slade
and the potential of him having a son
Damian and so on and so forth it's
exactly as you would expect and it's
kind of cool because Batman's basically
grasping at straws again Batman always
seems to kind of have it all figured out
and to put him in a position to where he
not only doesn't have it all figured out
but he's trying to figure it out and it
really seems desperate in the process
it's not something you normally see and
it's kind of cool and so in the midst of
all this somebody just kind of shows up
to slave Wilson in the desert the two of
them engaged in a bit of a conflict and
then of course this person ends up
defeating him and we end up realizing
this is Talia al Ghul and she says we
need to have a conversation about your
son basically you know her hinting to
the idea we to have a conversation about
Damian now at this point we transition
over to Deathstroke who's basically
taking out a guy by the name
of the human dynamos now the human
dynamos a concept was not created by
Christopher priests that actually goes
all the way back to quality comics which
I think was I want to say quality comics
was famous funnies
it's 1930s something comics um which
eventually basically like like that
version of human dynamo was pretty was
more more silly and comedic than
anything else I think he originally made
his debut in the police comics
storylines as far as far as I'm sorry as
part of quality comics and then
eventually you got an earth 2 version uh
who was Danford March that's what it was
his name was originally Danford March
and he was an enemy of her OVA of
Hawkman and then that goes into this
version ace Masterson who was basically
created by Christopher priest so again
uh the concept of human dynamos been
around for a long time but ace Masterson
was created by priests for the
Deathstroke story and what this
basically says is that he wears a kind
of utility belt to harness his own
energies which allowed him to do a wide
array of different things to basically
manipulate various forms of energy
around him you know like like kinetic
energy potential energy and radioactive
energy and you know all that different
all the different stuff I mean he was a
cold war-era character which is one of
the ways a DC released post-crisis um
after 1985 it was one of the ways at DC
introduced characters that would
normally have been part of like the
Justice Society
but were not part of a different
universe instead of saying that like
they they fought in a different reality
they just said they fought earlier than
all the other superheroes and then they
retired by the time like Batman Superman
Wonder Woman by the time they all came
along so it's a pretty smart move to
kind of invoke that thing but we don't
really know what's why it is that you
know human dynamo is being targeted by
Deathstroke outside of the fact that a
contract had to been put out on him but
of course Batman responds by saying look
I told you I was going to stop every
single thing you did and we end up kind
of flashing back for a second to this
conversation that Batman has when he
calls up Deathstroke and says look like
Deathstroke is shut down like so do not
go and do your thing do not go on
contracts or whatever every single
person you go after or that you have
existing contracts for that you haven't
taken care of
I've moved to like witness protection
and Deathstroke's kind of you know his
response here is yeah because that's
definitely gonna stop me Batman
witness protection witness protection
protects you from mobsters it does not
protect you from me and his end ooh this
is a cool moment this leaves you know
kind of jumping back to the fight
between between Batman and Deathstroke
the [ __ ] titties on exactly as you
would expect and is pretty evenly
matched you you're talking about very
prodigious fighters now of course
Deathstroke does have the upper hand on
Bruce em so far as he has like enhanced
strength and speed and you know a
healing factor and so on because of his
experimentation
but Bruce Wayne also has like a myriad
of fighting abilities pluses popularity
and so with his popularity as we know DC
wouldn't let him lose and so with that
happening we end up having like human
dynamics everything and basically says
look because of the powers that I have
I'm immortal
like I'm never going to die the problem
is that I'm getting older and so as I'm
getting older what it means is that I'm
losing my memory I'm suffering from
things well at least it's hinted at he's
suffering from like dementia or at least
having the early stages of dementia
having the early stages of things like
you know like like Alzheimer's or so on
and so forth but he's basically losing
control of his mental and physical
faculties and what this means is that
what the power he possesses if you lost
control entirely he could destroy the
world now something else Christopher
freeze hits on - which is kind of cool
is he actually sort of he basically says
ice Masterson was part of a cold war-era
group of superheroes called the Justice
experience now they died like that it's
kind of cool because it's like a
throwback to the Justice Society of
America and a cool little moment here
but what is up happening is Batman
responds by saying like I'm not gonna
let Deathstroke kill you we're gonna
send you to sanctuary now again
sanctuary is kind of an important thing
where we have visually like the
aftermath to the events of like flash
war and all this stuff
whereas basically DC hitting at this
place that sanctuary is the place heroes
go when they suffer like a crisis of
conscience but it's basically where he's
intending to get shuffled off to the
problems that his powers interfere with
the transporter and so where it seems
like the contract still on Deathstroke
takes him out because that's the task II
was assigned with so again it's kind of
messed up here but what we end up having
is is basically kind of inter spliced
over the course of this story so far we
had these things where we had like what
really looked like Tim Drake sending a
message to you're talking through
messages and saying look like these are
the things that I've that I've
discovered and these are the things that
are going on and but it's important that
you understand who your real dad is and
this message that's being sent by Tim
Drake is being watched by Damian Wayne
and so basically Damian's hearing it
straight from the horror at least as
close as he can from the horse's mouth
from Tim Drake that his father is in
fact Deathstroke and so it's just like
all things hint to that being the case
and it's kind of wild and so what we end
up doing here is basically picking up
with Damian Wayne who meets with
Deathstroke and then pledges his
allegiance to Slade and refers to him as
his father now this is again is another
moment where Chris release just sort of
does things and doesn't really give us
an explanation as to why the idea that
Damian would immediately betray Bruce
Wayne and say like well the DNA test
says it must be true so let's just go
with it and let's find out it seems
strange at the end of the day he's
extreme
loyal to Batman and so with that in mind
you would have to believe that he would
fight on the side of Bruce Lee he would
he would do some poking around and
investigating instead of just jumping in
and believing that that he's definitely
the son of Deathstroke now of course
this also coincides with the appearance
of a character named nightshade now in
reality this this event of IVA of Eve
Eden showing up here exactly the first
time she's appeared in DC Comics after
DC rebooted in 2011 and it kind of makes
sense because she was never really a
relevant character I mean she was like a
c-list character at best but she could
do a wider eight or not really a while
rate but she can do a few different
things that make her pretty dangerous
she can manipulate shadows she can
teleport people to the land of the
nightshades
um which basically is like a place of
where shadows kind of reign supreme she
can invoke a little bit of magic here
and there she's not by any means one of
DC's like most notable villains she's
peanuts she's small-time she's just kind
of here why it is if she gets into a
fight with Slade I don't really know I
swore a contractor or something along
those lines but the important thing here
is that she basically uses a bit of
magic casts a spell where Slade sue
protects him from the psychological
effects of it it does impact Damian and
Damian kind of like lashes out and
basically starts you know screaming and
he's like there's no possible way you're
my dad and almost kind of seems to refer
to his normal self and then in turn once
nightshade basically leaves he goes off
and he just kind of leaves and says okay
you know like there's no way that you're
my dad is it's kind of a strange
situation but following this we end up
having you know Bruce back in his house
you know and talking to Damian you know
a little bit about what's going on here
and we'll the two of them are sort of
bickering back and forth
Bruce kind of makes this offhand remark
you know when Damian kind of storms out
Bruce makes this offhand remark this
needs to be settled like it needs to be
taken care of and everything needs to be
put to an end and this is we find out
Slade had basically invaded Wayne Manor
now this is an important thing because
one of the indications here was that
Slade did not know Bruce Wayne was
Batman and in fact there's a point where
conversation goes on where Slade is
speculating why it is that Batman even
associates as Bruce Wayne in the first
place like what it is it's going on here
now of course at this point Slade really
puts his mind to task and this is really
like showcasing how smart he is the
juxtaposes Deathstroke to Batman and
says they are incredibly alike in terms
of their intelligence and the way this
happens is there's a substance called
mala denim I'm not sure exactly how you
pronounce that but basically saying like
this bunker that Bruce Wayne is in at
the moment this place where he's
basically hiding out I guess what passes
for Wayne Manor out here in the middle
of nowhere has been constructed by him
and it was designed for the purpose of
looking like it had always been here the
round was basically restored to its
original appearance even the dirt that
was originally there had been replaced
or had been restored to make it look
normal but Slade had picked up on the
fact that there is a substance in that
dirt that was not there originally now
is it a MacGuffin absolutely does it
work definitely it's one of those things
that you see a lot when it comes to the
counter books but it's kind of book fans
if we like the story enough we give it a
pass like we're very hypocritical in
that regard I've been that way for years
weirdoes kinda like hey look I really
like the story so we'll just kind of
sweep that under the rug we'll just kind
of ignore that a little bit but of
course this leads to Dick Grayson into
Damian Wayne showing up here now this is
one of the other important things to
bear in mind too this takes place before
Tim Drake comes back so it takes place
after the events of the colony which is
to say Detective Comics rebirth number
one or I guess Volume one
but before Tim Drake returns in the
event you know it's is basically Slade
saying like get them out of here this is
between you and me Batman responds by
saying yep this this is you and me and
so once they actually get downstairs but
the two of them just like start getting
into a fight like Batman switches off
the lights and the two of them just
start fighting one another and it's kind
of a cool thing because Slade is
basically trying to like figure out like
I mean he's still trying to figure out
what's going on but for the most part it
seems like he already has he's just kind
of playing along but with the two of
them fighting fighting against each
other like this is it's kind of
intriguing because it's sort of like a
knock-down drag-out fight it's one of
these things where it's like no one's
really in danger when Batman gets into a
fight with like Superman or Batman gets
into a fight with like Wonder Woman like
he didn't hit it hey and she beat the
hell out of him like what is when is
something like that Batman fights the
person he's fighting but also concerns
himself with like everybody around him
trying to make sure that like nobody
gets hurt whereas here it's just him and
Slade they're not powerful enough that
they're gonna like bring the foundation
down or anything like that you know so
they can just have like this sort of
knock-down drag-out fight and they do
you know it's like the fight scene from
they live where you have like Roddy
Piper and the one guy that did the Navy
commercials back in the day no he didn't
do the Navy commercials the one guy who
did like those those voices so and they
just beat the crap out of each other in
like a in an alley
there's no music no nothing you know put
all the glasses on dude I love that
movie I love they live that fight that
fight scene is so incredibly amazing but
still when they basically begin to come
to when Batman wakes up he just like
punches Slade Wilson who start fighting
again it's pretty cool it's a pretty
awesome little fight here now of course
it
the second little battle asked for like
a minute and a half and the two of them
basically you know end up coming out
even and with Batman being as injured as
he is with Slade Wilson recovering from
his injuries the two of them basically
have to work together now this is
grudging it's not something they really
want to do but it does kind of work is
right now you've got the FBI raiding the
compound of Wayne Manor you know because
of what Deathstroke and everybody else
did you know in terms of you know
sticking everything out there but it's
kind of a cool thing because Slade and
in Batman have kind of like this mutual
respect because they've both paid their
dues they've earned themselves you know
they they've they've earned their
current places in the DC Universe and so
there's a respect that comes in there
they don't really like each other but
they respect each other and that is the
important thing now from here we switch
back about several years before and we
end up finding out who it was that
simple
envelope and what we end up learning is
that right almost immediately after
Damian Wayne showed up that what Tim
Drake had done was perform a paternity
test Tim Drake had done a DNA test on
Damian and basically said like does
Bruce Wayne know Damian's not his son
and so like we ralpherz like was it was
never really my question to ask it's not
my job to you know I support master
Wayne or master Bruce and whatever was
it whatever is he ends up doing we end
up finding out that Tim Drake was the
one who got took the DNA test he put in
the envelope and he sent it off so that
it would be recovered by Bruce at some
point in the future and so it was like
Tim Drake was the one who set all this
in motion
Hendrick was the one who started all of
this and so in the middle of all this
you know when way managed being rated by
the FBI and so on and so forth this son
of Deathstroke of force icon who has
some mind-control powers to a degree
takes over the mind of an FBI agent
sends them back to Wayne Manor in tells
like basically tell everybody else I'm a
special agent in charge this is done
let's go court order basically says like
we're finished here everybody get out of
here but with the two of them you know
making their way back you know and you
know getting themselves back to rights
Damian Wayne shows up believing that
Deathstroke could kill Batman because
district said he's dead Damon doesn't
really get into a fight with him at all
it's basically like hey you know take
this get out of here you know grab your
dad get out of here like I'm leaving
nurse him back to health you know he
needs it because at the end of the day
I'm Deathstroke I've got a healing
factor and where people will say who
would win in a fight between Batman and
Deathstroke the evidence is right here
Deathstroke standing Batman is not ie
Deathstroke wins like it's it's a cool
little thing and now of course this
leads directly to Adaline Kane's showing
back up into you know and do it like
this meeting of sorts and then
Deathstroke standing there and basically
saying look like why did you switch the
DNA samples like through why'd you why
did you switch the DNA test and her
response is I don't know what you're
thing about I'm not the one who put out
false information telling you that that
Damian Wayne is not your son and so
that's what we end up finding out this
is actually Bruce Wayne in a death
stroke mask though real Slade went to go
meet with Talia al Ghul and he's the one
that figured it out that Talia al Ghul
was the one who switched the test
because she's the only one that really
had anything to gain by it there while
that while his ex-wife is vindictive and
while she does hate Slade there's
nothing to be gained here like it
wouldn't destroy slaves life this
impacts Batman it doesn't impact Slade
so from there when we kind of figure out
what's going on Talia basically says
like I wanted you to see what the world
could be like what we could be like
together if we were to work together and
and combine our resources but as always
slaves a one-man band
it's basically him just sort of doing
his own thing solo and so what we end up
doing is transitioning back to Wayne
Manor and we end up having the actual
DNA test an actual test that was done by
Bruce and Alfred to verify who the
father of Damian Wayne is and of course
as we expected we end up finding out it
is definitively Bruce that Bruce Wayne
is the father of Damian but it is a cool
thing it is a cool little story I mean
throwing Bruce's you know Bruce's
fatherhood into question it's a pretty
nice little thing here but let me know
what you guys think anyway we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]